JR.
♪
>> Tucker: WELL, GOOD
EVENING AND WELCOME TO
TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT.
THE NATION'S CAPITOL ALL BUT
DESERTED TODAY AFTER THE
ENTIRE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
UNEXPECTEDLY SHUT DOWN DUE
TO AN EMERGENCY.
DID YOU HEAR ABOUT THIS?
IT WASN'T AN EARTHQUAKE OR
OUTBREAK OF WAR, THE ACTUAL
REASON IT WAS WINDY TODAY IN
WASHINGTON.
THERE WAS NO RAIN OR
THUNDERSTORMS.
KIND OF NICE OUT.
IT WAS BLOWING BRISKLY LIKE
IT DOES A LOT OF YEAR IN
WYOMING AND MONTANA AND
SOUTH DAKOTA.
SO IN RESPONSE, THE ENTIRE
FEDERAL WORKFORCE STAYED
HOME WITH PAY.
BUT SOMEHOW THIS IS THE
AMAZING PART.
THE PRIVATE SECTOR BRAVELY
MADE IT TO WORK ANYWAY.
SO HERE WE ARE.
QUESTION IS COUNTY REST OF
US DEDUCT TODAY'S WIND
EMERGENCY FROM OUR FEDERAL
TAXES?
WE'LL ASK AROUND AND GET
BACK TO YOU ON THAT.
BUT FIRST, THE DEBATE OVER
THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
LAST NIGHT WE CRITICIZED THE
PRESIDENT FOR SAYING
AUTHORITIES OUGHT TO
CONFISCATE GUNS FIRST AND
WORRY ABOUT DUE PROCESS
LATER.
THAT IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL AS
WE POINTED OUT.
WE'RE PRETTY SURE THE
PRESIDENT IS RECONSIDERING
THAT.
NEWS REPORTS TODAY SAY HE
IS.
WE DIDN'T WANT TO LEAVE THE
IMPRESSION LAST NIGHT THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS THE
MAIN THREAT TO GUN RIGHTS OR
TO DUE PROCESS.
IT'S NOT.
IN FACT, IT'S NOT EVEN
CLOSE.
HERE'S A REMINDER OF HOW THE
OTHER SIDE FEELS ABOUT THOSE
THINGS.
>> FORCE THESE ALLEGEDLY
CHRISTIAN MEN AND WOMEN WHO
STUFF THEIR POCKETS WITH
MONEY FROM THE NRA YEAR
AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR TO DO
SOMETHING NOW.
>> SO MANY THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE ARE DYING EVERY YEAR
FOR THIS SO-CALLED LIBERTY.
>> YOU HAVE A WHOLE
GENERATION OF YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO ESSENTIALLY SEE THE NRA
AS THEIR ENEMY.
TO THEM THE NRA IS LIKE THE
KKK JUST SOME HOSTILE FORCE
THAT'S AGAINST THEM THAT'S
RISKING THEIR LIVES.
>> THE BIBLE WARNS US NOT TO
WORSHIP FALSE GODS AND, YET,
IT DOES SEEM THAT.
OF AMERICA IS, INDEED,
WORSHIPING AT THE ALTAR OF
THE GUN GODS.
>> Tucker: WE'RE GETTING
LECTURES ON CHRISTIANITY
FROM THE MEDIA.
PRETTY AMAZING.
TRUMP DID SAY SOMETHING
STUPID ABOUT DUE PROCESS THE
OTHER DAY AND THE FACT IS
THOUGH THAT THE LEFT HAS
BEEN OPPOSING DUE PROCESS
FOR A LONG TIME SPECIFICALLY
ON THE SUBJECT OF GUN
CONTROL.
WHEN IS THE LAST TIME YOU
HEARD A DEMOCRATIC
POLITICIAN PRAISE THE
AUSTRALIAN SOLUTION TO GUN
VIOLENCE?
A LOT IF YOU ARE WATCHING
CNN.
YOU PROBABLY HEARD IT TODAY.
THEY SAY IT ALL THE TIME.
THE QUESTION IS DO YOU KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT HOW AUSTRALIA
IMPLEMENTED GUN CONTROL?
WELL, CONFISCATION THEY TOOK
THE GUNS AWAY FROM THE
POPULATION BY FORCE NOT JUST
FROM CRIMINALS AND PEOPLE
CONVICTED OF WRONGDOING.
THE GOVERNMENT OF AUSTRALIA
TOOK GUNS FROM LAW ABIDING
PEOPLE WHO HAD DONE NOTHING
WRONG.
THEY PUNISHED THE INNOCENT.
WHAT EXACTLY DID THAT LOOK
LIKE?
WELL, HERE SAN AD FOR ONE OF
AUSTRALIA'S GUN CONFISCATION
EFFORTS.
SHOWS NAKED MEN IN A PRISON
SHOWER AND WARNS PUBLIC TO
TURN THEIR GUNS IN OR ELSE
THEY WILL BE SENT TO PRISON,
TOO.
EFFECTIVELY THE GOVERNMENT
THREATENED LAW ABIDING
CITIZENS WITH PRISON RAPE IF
THEY DIDN'T SURRENDER THEIR
GUNS.
THAT'S WHAT LIBERALS ARE
CALLING FOR IN THIS COUNTRY
EVERY TIME THEY TALK ABOUT
THE AUSTRALIA I CAN'T
BELIEVE SOLUTION.
A LOT MORE ADS LIKE THAT.
WE WILL TWEET THEM OUT
TONIGHT.
BY THE WAY THAT'S WHAT THE
ASSAULT WEAPONS BAN IS
DEMOCRATS PUSH FOR A LAW
OUTLAW MORE THAN 200 KINDS
OF FIREARMS, AS WELL AS ALL
GUNS THAT HAVE VARIOUS
IRRELEVANT COSMETIC FEATURES
LIKE BAYONET LUGS, LOTS OF
OTHER THINGS PEOPLE WROTE
THE LAW KNOW NOTHING ABOUT.
IF THAT LAW PASSES AND IT
MIGHT IF THE DEMOCRATS TAKE
CONGRESS, YOU WILL BE
PUNISHED.
YOU HAVE FEWER RIGHTS.
BUT, WAIT A SECOND, HAVE YOU
DONE NOTHING WRONG.
YOU NEVER SHOT ANYBODY.
HAVE YOU NO PLANS TO SHOOT
ANYBODY.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
DEMOCRATS WILL TREAT YOU THE
SAME WAY THEY TREAT
CONVICTED FELONS AS UNWORTHY
TO BE TRUSTED WITH YOU
FIREARMS.
MEANWHILE THEIR BODY GUARDS
WILL STILL HAVE THE MOST
POWERFUL GUNS AVAILABLE.
OF COURSE THEY WILL, BECAUSE
THEY CAN.
BECAUSE THEY ARE IN CHARGE
AND YOU ARE NOT.
THE LEFT IS ALSO DEMANDING
THE GOVERNMENT BAR PEOPLE
UNDER 21, THESE ARE PEOPLE
ELIGIBLE TO VOTE AND SERVE
IN THE MILITARY FROM BUYING
FIREARMS.
AGAIN, MOST PEOPLE UNDER 21
HAVEN'T DONE ANYTHING WRONG.
THEY HAVEN'T BEEN CONVICTED
OF A CRIME OR COMMITTED
CRIMES.
BUT A FEW OF THEM HAVE.
SO DEMOCRATS ARE SAYING ALL
MUST BE PUNISHED.
IMAGINE APPLYING THE SAME
STANDARD TO OTHER
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
FOR EXAMPLE, LET'S SAY
SOMEBODY SHOUTED FIRE IN A
CROWDED THEATER AND SCORES
DIED.
WOULD THE REST OF US LOSE
OUR RIGHT TO FREE SPEECH?
THESE ARE REAL QUESTIONS.
THEY ARE INCONVENIENT SO
SOON AFTER THE MASSACRE IN
PARKLAND FOR WHICH THE
COUNTRY IS STILL GRIEVING,
BUT WE SHOULD REMEMBER THEY
IS A COUNTRY WORTH LIVING IN
PRECISELY BECAUSE WE TAKE
THE CONSTITUTION SERIOUSLY.
WHEN WE STOP TAKING IT
SERIOUSLY IT, WON'T BE A
COUNTRY WORTH LIVING.
IN PRESIDENT TRUMP SEEMS TO
HAVE REMEMBERED THAT.
MANY ON THE LEFT NEVER KNEW
IT AND THEY DON'T CARE
ANYWAY.
YOU OFTEN HEAR PROGRESSIVES
SAY THEY WANT AN HONEST
CONVERSATION ABOUT GUNS.
WELL, OF COURSE WE DO TOO.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE INVITED
THE HEADS OF ALMOST EVERY
DIFFERENT GUN CONTROL GROUP
TO COME ON THIS SHOW AND
TELL THEM WHAT THEY BELIEVE.
MIKE BLOOMBERG GROUP, GEORGE
SOROS' GROUP.
THEY REFUSE TO COME ON.
DELIGHTED TO APPEAR ON CNN,
OBVIOUSLY WHERE THEY'RE
CELEBRATED AND NEVER
CHALLENGED.
WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION BECAUSE WE
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT.
WE ARE JOINED BY SOMEONE WHO
WILL COME ON ANTWON C.
WRIGHT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU, TUCKER, FOR
HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: I APPRECIATE IT
BECAUSE SO MANY OTHERS WITH
YOUR VIEWS WON'T.
IT'S AN ANALOGY BUT I THINK
IT'S STILL WORTH TALKING
ABOUT.
I JUST MENTIONED A MINUTE
AGO ABOUT ANOTHER
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT, THE
FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
IF SOMEONE WERE TO MISUSE
THAT FREEDOM, IN A WAY THAT
WAS ILLEGAL WOOLG THAT MEAN
REST OF US WOULD HAVE TO
GIVE UP OUR RIGHT TO THE
FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
WE ALL HAVE TO TAKE A DEEP
BREATH AND FOCUS ON THE
ISSUE AT HAND.
FOR ME THE FOCUS ON THE
ISSUE AT HAND IS TRYING TO
PREVENT P FIGURE OUT HOW TO
PREVENT ANOTHER MASS
SHOOTING IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> SO ONE MORE PARENT CAN
SEE, CANNOT HAVE TO DEAL
WITH BURYING THEIR CHILD
ONCE AGAIN.
>> Tucker: I AGREE.
AMEN.
>> TUCKER, I DON'T WANT TO
MAKE THIS ABOUT LEFT OR
RIGHT, LIBERAL OR
CONSERVATIVE.
THIS IS SIMPLY ABOUT TRYING
TO DO SOMETHING TO PREVENT
ANOTHER MASS SHOOTING.
>> Tucker: OBVIOUSLY.
HOLD ON.
I TOTALLY AGREE WITH THAT I
THINK EVERY DECENT PERSON,
MAYBE EVEN SOME NON-DECENT
PEOPLE HERE.
NOBODY THINKS THESE ARE
GOOD.
THEY ARE HURTING THE COUNTRY
WE ARE ALL AGAINST THEM.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT DO YOU
DO?
THEY ARE POLICY SOLUTIONS
BEING FLOAT YOU HAD.
ARE THEY GOOD IDEAS OR
CONSISTENT WITH THE
CONSTITUTION OR NOT?
WHAT IS THE SOLUTION TO
THESE SHOOTINGS THAT YOU
THINK WOULD WORK?
>> HERE IS WHAT I THINK
REASONABLE PEOPLE BELIEVE.
WE KNOW NORTH OF 65% OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE BELIEVE WE
SHOULD DO SOMETHING.
HERE IS WHAT I THINK WE
SHOULD DO.
I'M NOT ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE
WHO SAY WE NEED TO TAKE AWAY
EVERYONE'S GUNS.
I KNOW THAT'S THE FALL BACK
REPUBLICANS TALK DEMOCRATS
WANT TO.
I'M A PROUD WEAPONNISH.
I APPRECIATE BEING ABLE TO
CARRY THIS GUN FREELY IN MY
COUNTRY.
HERE IS WHAT I DO BELIEF, IF
YOU HAVE A MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUE THERE IS A GOOD CHANCE
YOU SHOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
HAVE A FIREARM.
>> Tucker: I AGREE.
>> IF WE CAN CLOSE THE
LOOPHOLE.
MY GOOD FRIEND SHE MEN AT A
WAS KILLED IN A CHURCH IN
CHARLESTON BECAUSE DYLAN
ROOF PURCHASED A GUN WHEN A
CHECK DIDN'T COME ABOUT BACK
IN CERTAIN AMOUNT OF DAYS.
>> Tucker: HAD YOU TO FILL
THIS OUT ON A FEDERAL FUND
ADJUDICATED MENTALLY ILL.
YOU CAN'T BUY A GUN.
THAT'S ALREADY THE LAW.
SO WHAT CHANGES WOULD YOU
MAKE SINCE, AGAIN, THAT'S
ALREADY THE LAW?
>> WELL, HERE'S THE THING.
DIFFERENT STATES HAVE
DIFFERENT LAWS.
RECENTLY IN SOUTH CAROLINA.
>> Tucker: NO, NO, I'M SORRY
TO INTERRUPT.
THAT'S FEDERAL.
THAT'S ON THE FEDERAL FORM.
THE FEDERAL BACKGROUND CHECK
THE DOJ DOES ON EVERY GUN
OWNER.
IF YOU BUY A GUN, YOU HAVE
TO FILL THIS OUT.
AND YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
BUY A GUN IF YOU HAVE BEEN
ADJUDICATED MENTALLY ILL.
WHAT SPECIFIC CHANGE WOULD
YOU MAKE?
>> WELL, I THINK THE WORD
ENDS ILLNESS VARIES.
ONE DOCTOR CAN DIAGNOSE YOU
ONE THING AND ONE THE OTHER.
WE NEED TO BE CONSISTENT
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES.
THAT'S JUST ONE THING I
WOULD CHANGE.
>> Tucker: I MEAN WHAT WOULD
THE CHANGE -- I DON'T WANT
TO BE ABSTINENT I WANT TO
GET TO THE SPECIFICS HERE.
SPECIFICS MATTER IT'S PUBLIC
POLICY.
WHAT SPECIFIC CHANGE WOULD
YOU MAKE?
>> THE ISSUE SPECIFICALLY ON
MENTAL HEALTH.
IN SOME PLACES PEOPLE WITH
MENTAL ILLNESSES CAN GO INTO
A GUN SHOW OR ONLINE AND BUY
A WEAPON.
YOU AND I BOTH KNOW THAT.
>> Tucker: WE JUST SAW THAT
HAPPEN IN FLORIDA.
A KID WITH MENTAL ILLNESS
WAS ABLE TO BUY A GUN
BECAUSE THE SCHOOL REFUSED
TO TURN HIM OVER -- HOW
WOULD YOU STOP THAT?
WHAT WOULD YOU DO
SPECIFICALLY.
>> THAT'S MY POINT.
WE HAVE TO HAVE
COMPREHENSIVE EXTENSIVE
BACKGROUND CHECKS SO THAT WE
CAN PREVENT ANOTHER
PERSON -- PREVENT ANOTHER
PERSON WHO HAS MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES FROM HAVING A GUN.
>> Tucker: HERE IS WHERE WE
ARE HAVING AN ACTUAL
BIPARTISAN CONVERSATION.
WE BOTH AGREE MENTALLY ILL,
DANGEROUS PEOPLE SHOULDN'T
HAVE GUNS.
WHAT DO YOU DO SPECIFICALLY?
WE ALREADY HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE BACK GROUND
CHECK.
WOULD YOU, I DON'T KNOW,
TELL ME YOUR SOLUTION.
I'M SINCERELY INTERESTED.
>> WELL, TUCKER, IF YOU
WOULD LET ME FINISH GETTING
THROUGH, WE WILL HAVE TO
TIGHTEN UP ON CLOSING THE
BEGAN TO MAKE SURE THESE
LAWS ARE IN PLACE AND MAKING
SURE THEY ARE TRULY
ENFORCED.
>> Tucker: THE LAW IS THERE.
>> ENFORCE WANTED.
THERE IS LAWS ON THE BOOK
AND HAVE TO ENFORCE THEM AND
STRENGTHEN THEM WHERE WE
NEED TO.
I THINK YOU CAN AGREE WITH
THAT RIGHT, TUCKER?
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THAT MEANS IT DOESN'T MEAN
ANYTHING U IT'S THE KIND OF
THING THAT ALL OF US, JIMMY
KIMMEL CAN NOD AND FEEL
VERTUOUS.
>> IT MEANS ENFORCING THE
LAWS ON THEIR OWN BOOKS.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE I'M
FOUR THAT LET ME ASK YOU A
QUESTION THOUGH SINGS WE ARE
ON THIS SUBJECT, THERE ARE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS, CLOSE
TO HALF A MILLION RETURNING
VETERANS FROM IRAQ AND
AFGHANISTAN WHO GET MONEY
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
A LOT OF THEM ARE ON
MEDICATION BECAUSE THEY HAVE
A MENTAL ILLNESS.
THEY HAVE SAID THAT IT'S
CALLED PTSD SHOULD THEY BE
ALLOWED TO BUY GUNS.
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
CAN YOU FUNDAMENTALLY
DISAGREE.
I DON'T THINK SO.
>> Tucker: LOOK, I'M JUST
SEARCHING FOR HONEST ANSWERS
FOR PEOPLE.
I DON'T HAVE TO AGREE.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT YOU
THOUGHT.
YOU SAID IT HONESTLY.
>> TUCKER, CAN I GIVE YOU A
FOR NO MORE THINGS.
>> Tucker: ALMOST OUT OF
TIME BUT HIT ME REAL QUICK.
>> WE WE AGREE YOU THIS ARE
URCHESD OUT AGE YOU HAVE 18